PETE: FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS CALLING ARRESTS FOR
MASK MANDATE VIOLATIONS AND
OVER REACH BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AS HE’S NOW PARDONING FLORIDIANS
PUNISHED FOR COVID-19 VIOLATIONS
HERE NOW TO REACT IS FLORIDA LT.
GOVERNOR, JEANETTE NUNEZ.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
SO PARDONS TO FOLKS WHO WERE
CRACKED DOWN UPON FOR COVID
VIOLATIONS.
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING, PETE.
IT’S AN HONOR TO BE HERE WITH
YOU THIS MORNING, AND REALLY,
WHAT WE’VE SEEN IS GOVERNOR
DESANTIS SYSTEMATICALLY CHISSEL
LING AWAY AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OVERREACH, AND REALLY
, WHAT I BELIEVE WERE
DRACONIAN MEASURES PASSED UPON
FLORIDIANS SO THE GOVERNOR
WASN’T CONTENT TO LET THESE
CIVIL AND CRIMINAL PENALTIES
CONTINUE, SO HE ISSUED A FULL
AND CATEGORICAL PARDON.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE SERVING JAIL TIME
FOR VIOLATING A MASK MANDATE.
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT WE WEREN’T
ALLOWED, WE WEREN’T GOING TO
ALLOW TO HAPPEN.
PETE: PERSONALLY IN OTHER STATE,
GYM OWNERS, SALON OWNERS, WHO
WILL STILL SUFFERING UNDER THE
WEIGHT OF PENALTIES AND FEES
, SO YOU’RE SAYING WITH THIS
MOVE, IF THERE WERE HEALTH
INSPECTIONS OR  SOMEONE WEARING
A MASK WHERE THEY SHOULDN’T HAVE
, THAT ORDEAL FOR THEM IS
OVER?
>> INDEED, AND WHAT I WOULD
TELL THOSE PEOPLE FROM OTHER
STATES SUFFERING UNDER THE
WEIGHT OF THESE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MANDATES AND STATE
MANDATES COME ON DOWN TO FLORIDA
WE’RE OPEN, WE’RE FREE, AND
WE’RE BOOMING.
PETE: WHAT WAS THE KEY, YOU KNOW
IT WAS AN EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2020 THAT THE
GOVERNOR THERE SIGNED
OPENING ALL FLORIDA BUSINESSES
REGARDLESS OF LOCAL RESTRICTIONS
WHAT GAVE HIM AND YOU GUYS THE
ABILITY TO FORESEE HOW
IMPORTANT THAT BE FOR PEOPLE?
>> OH, GOVERNOR DESANTIS,
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC,
UNDERSTOOD THAT WE NEEDED TO
BALANCE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF FLORIDIANS, BUT
ALSO MAKE DECISIONS THAT WERE
GOING TO EMPOWER FLORIDIANS AND
MAKE DECISIONS ON THEIR OWN,
ALLOW BUSINESSES TO OPERATE,
ALLOW PEOPLE TO GO TO WORK.
WE WEREN’T IN THE BUSINESS OF
DEEMING WHOSE JOB WAS ESSENTIAL
OR  WHOSE BUSINESS WAS ESSENTIAL
, AND WHOSE WASN’T.
SO GOVERNOR DESANTIS, CONTRARY
TO THE CRITICS AND THE PUNDITS
AND THE LIBERAL ELITES AND THE
CORPORATE MEDIA, HE MADE
DECISIONS BASED ON ACTUAL
SCIENCE, WHICH IS WHY YOU SAW
HIM ELIMINATING CERTAIN
RESTRICTIONS, WHICH IS WHY YOU
SAW HIM OPENING UP SCHOOLS SO
THAT PARENTS COULD SEND THEIR
KIDS TO GET A QUALITY EDUCATION,
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY, WHEN
PEOPLE WANT TO CRITICIZE I THINK
THE OUTCOMES ARE CLEAR, THE
EVIDENCE IS OUT, AND
GOVERNOR DESANTIS HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN MANAGING THE PANDEMIC
AND MAKING SURE THAT FLORIDIANS
WERE PUT FIRST.
PETE: YEAH, THE COURAGE OF
LEADERS IS EXPOSED IN MOST
CRITICAL MOMENTS ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE CHORUS IS SAYING SOMETHING
ELSE AND THEY DECIDE TO GO
AGAINST IT, AND ON THE SIDE OF
AVERAGE PEOPLE AND COMMON SENSE,
AND GOVERNOR DESANTIS HAS
CERTAINLY DONE THAT.